a cute couples photo or is it while the
other five people in the pic are all
smiles and snuggles Ryan Reynolds's well
this and the Internet's taking notice I
now know what to call the Deadpool
sequel Deadpool that inside Ryan
Reynolds internal monologue daddy needs
to express some rage current mood Ryan
Reynolds looking internally pained by
hiddles wits there's even this meme of
Ryan and desperate search for help but
why is he in so much anguish here's Ryan
earlier that day frolicking with wife
Blake and the rest of Taylor's squad and
seemingly enjoying the summer fun but if
you take a closer look it's gonna
professional photographer yeah I see
that yep Taylor hired a professional
photog to make sure every candid moment
was caught on camera and it worked
yesterday afternoon Instagram was
bombarded with pictures from Taylor's
star-packed soiree Ryan seems to be
channeling the too much hit Swift camp
that keeps on growing ever since that
Sun cover of them kissing went viral
it's been sighting after citing after
citing the cherry on top of this steamy
Sunday piggyback piggyback the tank top
Tom war in front of all of Taylor's
friends that reads I heart TS but that's
also why many people aren't buying it
now the best part of all this are the
conspiracy theories which really I'm
starting to believe them myself that
this romance is actually more of a foam
ants and that Taylor is pulling an
unbelievable troll job on you me and
everybody else and that this whole
relationship is actually them filming a
new music video that she will release
sort of like what Beyonce always does
you have Taylor being very public when
is Taylor ever been dis accessible with
any of her other relationships give the
same camera crew following them all over
the place also Tom Hiddleston in the
iheart TS t shirt not gonna happen
you